>> Hello, everyone. Welcome
to the first session.
So, we'll have three talks
in that session.
First talk, Semantic
Matching Against
Corpus: New Application
and Method,
presented by Lucy Lin.
So, the talk will be for
20 minutes. Thank you.
>> Sweet. Can everyone
hear me okay?
>> Yeah.
>> Awesome. Thanks. Hi, I'm Lucy,
and I'm going to
be talking about,
it will come back.
Semantic matching
against text corpora,
and this is in collaboration
with Scott Miles
and Noah Smith at
the University of Washington.
So, we've clearly made a
lot of recent advances
in modeling sentential semantics
like a lot of the analyte tasks,
semantic similarity,
paraphrase, et cetera.
So, what we going to
propose is that
a natural thing to do
is to match
natural language propositions
against the corpus.
We see possible end-users
as, for example,
a historian of science
being interested in
tracking the idea of
vaccines cause autism.
You might expect
a spike in news after,
say, the Andrew Wakefield
article about that.
Similarly, political scientists
might be interested in
how different framings
of policy issues occur,
or public servants dealing
with recovery after
natural disasters
might be interested in
ideas about well-being
or recovery.
So, this is the use
case we imagine,
where a user specifies a query
like dealing with authorities
is causing stress and anxiety.
We will query the corpus,
return a list of match sentences.
For example, those in
charge of recovery are
making moves to appease
anger among homeowners.
At the end of the talk, I'll
briefly touch on what we
might be able to do with
a list of matched sentences,
which is to maybe have
proxy measurement across
a variable like time.
This is related to, as I
mentioned, work on entailment,
semantics similarity, but there's
also really work in
information retrieval,
specifically passage retrieval
for question answering,
and also on the measurement side,
it's similar in spirit to
dynamic topic models
and related work.
So, how is this going to go?
I'm going to formalize this
a little bit, and then,
talk about two different
applications: one in
which we use examples
from a codebook,
and this is the media
framing domain,
and then, a second in which we
have our domain expert, Scott,
specify queries of ideas
that he's interested
in disaster recovery,
and then, we did a user study
to validate that and see if
they're interested end users.
Finally, I'll briefly discuss
this using the output
for measurement idea.
So, basically as inputs,
we would have a
corpus of sentences,
which we'll say C, and
a proposition query containing
the idea of interests,
which will call as P.
We'll just treat
these as sentences.
We're not going to consider
document structure in this work,
but would be interesting
in future work.
What we'd like to do
is, basically score
all these sentences
as in C such that
the score should be high
if and only if S expresses
the proposition query SP.
From there, you can get
the top end sentences,
and return out the list.
So, I'm going to talk about
this first application,
where we're going to use
the Media Frames Corpus,
which contains thousands of
articles about
different policy issues.
The one we're going to
focus on is immigration,
and spans of texts
are annotated with
different framing dimensions.
These are things like, if
the issue is
constant legal terms,
and economic terms, quality
of life, and so on.
We also have the annotation
codebook for that corpus,
and we're going to take
30 annotation codebook examples
as the ideas of interests.
One example of this
is immigration rules
have changed on
fairly over time which invokes
this framing of
fairness and equality
with relation to immigration.
So the idea basically
is that if we
match an example sentence
from the codebook,
then it should evoke the frame
that we're expecting,
that it's an example of.
Just as a side note,
there are many ways
to invoke a frame
outside the codebooks,
so we're not really looking
for like high recall at all ,
we're just looking
at precision here.
So because we're evoking frames
and it's a broad category
where the user really
simple scoring function.
Basically, what we're going to
do is on each sentence we will
represent as the average
of its word vectors,
and then we're going to
take the cosine similarity
between the two sentence vectors,
and that's going to be
the scoring function.
We try out two
different word vector
variants that are pretrained.
One are paraphrastic word
vectors by waiting at all,
and these are trained on the PDB.
They're designed to be used
in these similarity tasks.
The other is the very
well-known Word2Vec
pre-trained on Google News,
and the nice thing about this is
that because they're
trained on structured data,
they might have a lot of
entities we're interested in.
So, we're interested
in how well does
our output line up with
the corpus annotations.
So, we look at this at
the sentence level where
if we match this sentence,
does the frame line up
with the annotated frame?
What we find is basically
that the paraphrastic
vectors do better
than the Word2vec vectors
which in turn do
better than just a
TF-IDF baseline.
So we're not really looking for,
they're clearly probably
better methods to
do this to get
much higher precision,
but this is a first step,
and does really well
given how simple it is.
So, there we go.
Secondly, I'm going to talk
about matching
more specific queries.
This is going to be in
a domain where researchers and
public servants don't necessarily
have lot empirical data,
and they want to understand what
challenges the
community is facing as
a postmortem for
post-disaster work.
So, our thinking is that we
can use these techniques to
find relevant sentences from
which they can,
fortunately, learn from.
So we're going to
specifically focus on
the Canterbury earthquakes
New Zealand from 2010,2011.
We pulled a corpus
of about a thousand news articles
that are from local news sources,
and as ideas of interest,
we had our domain expert, Scott,
provide 20 queries like
he's interested in
for his own work.
These are things
covering community
well being, infrastructural,
decision-making utilities, so on.
For example,
the council should have
consulted residents
before making decisions,
seems obvious apparently it's
not to certain governments.
So, in this case,
unlike in the framing
case we're really
interested in more
fine-grained matching,
really went to match this idea.
So, because of that,
we're going to
use a more entailment model.
It's going to be based on syntax,
and I'm going to walk
through very quickly.
So, given two sentences,
the candidate sentence
from the corpus,
and the proposition query,
we're going to get
the dependency parses of each.
We're then going to find
a sequence of what we're calling
tree edit operations
which transform
one tree into the other.
So, the intuition
basically is that
the difference between
the two sentence is
somehow indicative
of the relationship
between the tailor fits,
if they match each
other, if they don't,
and this syntactic transformation
is one way of getting at that.
To be more clear, we
can take this example
where we start with
the sentence
unfamiliar bureaucratic
systems are causing stress,
and we want to find a set of
transformations such that we
end up with this tree
at the bottom,
and so you might want to
delete a couple of the words,
relabel, and then finally
you insert to get the entry.
I'm not going to go into
details about how we do this,
but it's basically a research.
From there, we use that sequence
as features into a classifier,
the original paper
from Heilman and Smith
that we worked off of use
logistic regression
classifier with
based on counts of features.
This is 2018, so
we're going to also put
into in neural networks.
It's a sequence and
we should do that.
We just trained it on as SNLI,
stands for Natural
Language Inference Corpus,
and just two class entail
versus neutral contradiction.
So, to make this run in
a reasonable amount of time,
we first do this fast word
vector based matching
on entire corpus obtain
some subset of matches from which
we then run this
entailment based model,
and we tried out
different combinations of these.
So, to evaluate, we survey
20 emergency managers,
and took the output of
the different systems,
and had them rate
from one to five
how good of a match they were
to come here to the query.
So, an example that we showed
them is there's a shortage
of construction workers,
and so one is like this is not
really expressing idea at all
to five which is,
"Hey, this is great."
So, what we see is
that on the left are,
the left two are basically we use
the paraphrastic vectors in
this like first parse filter,
and then they're between
the two sides they are
the logistic regression
Ellis TM versions
of the syntax-based model.
In general, the
paraphrastic vectors
again do better
the word [inaudible] ,
and this makes a difference
on what you do afterwards.
Basically, if you have
mediocre output from
that first parse,
you're not really going
to make things better.
We also asked respondents
if they're just interested
in this application.
In general, most of them
said yes, which is great,
and then half of them were
actually interested in
a follow-up study which is
it progress, and basically,
we're having them specify
their own idea of queries,
and so it's like this back and
forth study, which is cool.
So, finally, I'm going
to talk about using
this output in like
a measurement.
What I mean by that is, say,
we have this query,
"Dealing with authorities is
causing stress and anxiety."
That's been kind of using
throughout this talk,
and if we take.
>> It's supposed to be fixed.
>> It's okay. There we go.
If we take the top 50 sentences,
we look at the metadata for
the articles they came from.
They're published
on certain date,
which kind of indicates, oh, hi.
This idea showing
up at this time.
If we've done this
in three months,
we get the following histogram.
So, we showed this guy and he
was like, "This is interesting."
That's kind of worrisome.
Unfortunately.
>> They're trying to fix it.
>> It's like Window reboot.
Basically, after
the earthquake happens,
which was kind of 0.11ish.
People are still kind,
they are feeling okay
about the fact that
they're getting help,
the governments they're involved
in giving aid in terms of
recovery, services et cetera.
As time goes on,
worry and stress starts to set in
because their needs
aren't being fulfilled,
or they feel like
they're being forgotten,
and so that translates
into subsequent coverage.
So, some things that we found for
both studies that kind of
motivate future work are,
one, the complexity of that idea.
So, sometimes queries that are
too general, too specific.
That impacts, the kinds of
matched sentences you get,
and also can we give user guides
for maybe writing better queries.
So, that's kind of progress
with this follow-up study.
So, another problem we
ran into was,
Entities/Coreference.
This is particularly
interesting in
New Zealand earthquake data
because a lot of those entities
just they don't,
they're local, they don't
really show up in our news.
An example of this
is CERA which is
the Canterbury Earthquake
Recovery Authority.
There's apparently also
the last name of an actor who,
I didn't know existed.
Finally, there just, the
fact that we're using,
we're kind of breaking
off sentence boundaries
is a limiting factor.
So, in two ways.
One, discerning cut contexts
can invalidate a match.
Secondly, potential match can
be spread across a sentence
boundary, so we'll miss it.
So, in future work, it
would be interesting to
incorporate that or
document structure, so on.
So, just to wrap up,
in this talk we showed
the kind of viability of
different semantic
matching methods and
two pretty different
application domains.
We performed a user
study to establish
some end user interest at least
in this particular application,
and motivated future work on
semantic matching and
other measurement applications.
Thanks.
Questions? Yeah.
>> You mentioned one of
next step is to ask,
would you write good queries?
How do you value what
is a better query
and what is not a good query?
>> So, you're asking
basically on,
how we are getting
them or like write
better queries and how
we might evaluate that?
>> If we're asked to evaluate
the quality of your queries.
>> Yeah. So, in this
follows study we're not,
we basically ask them like,
what would you write?
As a query without
giving suggestions.
They're actually
somewhat different
from the ones that
Scott provided.
So, it's probably
going to be more of
this back and forth thing
of us seeing how well,
what kind of output we get
from these new queries?
How well they score
in terms of like,
the expected output
that they want to see,
and then going back
and being like, "Oh,
well maybe you should
simplify this in
the future." Does
that make sense?
>> Yeah?
>> Yeah.
>> More question, we have time.
>> This is about
your complexity about
when you find entities
with the same name.
>> Yeah.
>> Is there going to be a problem
because a lot of
things and I'll be,
what is your gazes idea
for handling that in
the next project?
>> So, the question is how
will we plan on handling kind
of entities that shows same name,
but maybe just appear
in different domains?
I'm not sure yet to be honest.
I mean one thing we can
think about is kind
of getting a small amount
of label data and
the target domain,
and then doing a little bit of
domain adaptation sort
of stuff to make lot,
perhaps less of a problem,
but that's also kind
of in progress.
>> Any more question?
>> I have, a medium one like.
Just interesting or
maybe more of a comment.
One thing that might be
interesting to play with is,
there's a Corpus of
CNN and Daily Mail Articles
that you've encountered that.
>> I've seen it.
>> Okay. So, they have
the highlights of
the article and
then the article itself,
and so it's an
abstractive sentence.
They could relate to that,
that could be a fun.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. Some tremendous.
>> Yeah. So, I guess the comment
if people didn't hear was that,
the CNN Daily Mail
Corpus would be
an interesting thing
to apply this to.
>> I have a question regarding
the completion of
the Word2Vector.
You edit the Word2Vector
for composing.
Did you try any other method?
>> So, the question is, if we try
other methods besides
just kind of simple addition
of the word vectors and
the kind of the basic
word vector matching.
So, this was kind of motivated by
that lighting paper with him
which they had found that,
simple averaging for
their vectors had
actually worked better than
using [inaudible] or something.
I think they since have
subsequent results
which have kind of modified that,
and so I would probably try
something else in the future.
But one thing that's
nice about it is just
really how simple it is,
and it still gives
a decent signal.
>> Any more question? Okay, let's
do the things that
we could again.
>> Thanks.
>> So, I think
a natural noise was
a neural machines composition
while you [inaudible].
>> Hi, this is
some joint work I'll be
presenting that I did with
Sanjana Yonatan sorry,
I'm doing this joint
work with Yonatan.
As he mentioned,
this is our talk,
Synthetic and Natural Noise
both Break Neural
Machine Translation.
What I've gone ahead and
done for you here is,
I've just left in where
the spell checker has
decided there's an error.
So, that's all these red lines.
The beautiful thing is you
might be thinking, well,
maybe he will make typos,
these are actually
all real mistakes that
people have made.
So, what we did,
this is from Wiki-edits corpus.
So, I just went ahead and swapped
in the mistakes that people make,
and you might be thinking well,
not to worry, machine
translation is really robust,
spellcheckers are really robust.
First, I'll run that
and see what it fixes.
So, not to worry what we end
up with is a much better version.
So, Synthetic ant Natural noise
doth Break Neural
Machine Translation.
It's also figured
out my pseudonym,
which is Yucatan Busk.
So, we've made a lot
of progress here.
It's also much more
Shakespearean,
which I feel like
gives it a sort of
gravitas that was
missing from the title.
So, clearly spell checking is,
sort of, not perfect, it's nice.
In English, in particular,
we have a lot of
''did you mean'' kind
of data so that really helps.
Then obviously, here
is the actual title,
here are our actual names.
So, the sort of basic,
placed with a situates
in the literature right,
is in this context of things
like adversarial examples.
We're very familiar with
this classic example from
the vision literature, right?
Where you have an image which
was classified as a panda,
you add what is seemingly sort of
imperceptible noise and now
you have a misclassification.
The question becomes, sort of,
what does that look like
for natural language?
What's important right
is that the noise
distorts the perceptual
process in some way,
but it doesn't actually
hinder the semantic
understanding.
So, maybe you did notice that
the second image was
a little bit blurrier,
but it didn't actually
affect your ability to
understand what it was.
This is not a typical right
of our perceptual systems,
for example, our eyes
also caught all over
the place, all the time.
It sort of gives you
a little bit of that,
this is not in the paper, but
some work we've been
doing since then.
If you take some texts,
you go ahead and introduce
the same kind of errors
that I showed earlier.
So, here we have
a lawsuit, was filed
March 27th and the
preliminary investigation,
was opened by the prosecutors.
First of all, it's
important to note that
no one has any trouble
reading this.
Just to prove that point,
we went ahead and
run an eye tracker.
So, we had people sit down
and actually reading
this sentence.
So, we have this sort
of fix it here,
they jump a little bit,
move forward the entire phrase,
backtrack and then move through
the rest of the sentence.
The only reason this is really
important is that
there are 14 words,
there are nine fixations.
So, when people are
reading this text
and we actually have
them answering
questions at the end to
make sure that they did
comprehend the text,
they're not paying a lot
of attention to a
lot of the words.
In fact, based on what we know
about how much you
see when you look at
a specific part of the sentence
would probably happened in
this fixation as they saw
the entire word completely
skipped was, and then moved on.
Right. So they
probably didn't even
notice which we
see, for instance,
there are some
interesting work in
the psych literature where
you interview people,
didn't even notice that
there was an error
there. We do this
all the time, right?
We make mistakes in
our own writing,
we then reread it
and totally miss it.
We need a new pair of
eyes to notice it.
So, perception is fundamentally
noisy and sparse.
So, maybe the reason
that we aren't
disturbed by these kinds
of adversarial examples,
is because we've been
sort of training
on it our entire lives.
Another place you
might be training on
these things is
messy handwriting, right?
Your entire life you're
trying to decipher
doctor's notes or other kinds
of things maybe your child wrote.
You may yourself have
really messy handwriting and,
so I went ahead and
did some research,
I went online and I searched and
it looks like if you
have messy handwriting,
you might have emotional baggage.
So, that, you know,
just take that home.
On the other hand, I did
continue searching and if you
go further down on
the results you might
also be a genius.
So, it's a little unclear what
the research shows there,
but either way you've
probably been exposed to
noisy texts throughout your life.
So, what we're doing
in this setup is I'm
just going to give
you The Super Quick.
We have a bunch of models
which we're going to test and see
how brittle they are and
how noise affects them.
So, first we use Nematus which is
the machine translation framework
which perform very
well in a bunch
of WMT tasks from last year.
It's a BPE based representations,
if you're not familiar,
that just means that
instead of using words as
input and sort of finding
sets of characters,
that for instance, like
a morphological ending like
ING gets chunked out.
So, this is a really
helpful way of
increasing robustness to
out-of-vocabulary effects.
We're then also going
to use this work
from Taco last year
chart-to-chart.
This is a very impressive
model that doesn't
even take into account
segmentation information.
So, it just treats
the entire input as
one big character stream and
then translates to characters.
Then finally, just as
a simple baseline what you
might code up in an afternoon.
So, this is your sequence-to-sequence
model with attention
and character-based convolutions
for the representation.
So, it's not super important.
The thing to keep in mind is
just that this final model
here and has notions of
what word boundaries are but
looks at individual characters.
This model doesn't even
care about word boundaries,
and this top model has
maybe slightly more
intelligent ways of
figuring out morphological
units and so forth.
Then for the data,
we're going to use
a spoken text corpus.
So, the IWSLT competition
in couple of years back,
they had a bunch
of these Ted Talks
and their translations.
So, that's what we're
going to do the evaluation
and then also some of
the training I'll show you.
So, first let's talk
about synthetic errors.
So, the beauty of adversarial
examples that exist,
for instance,
in the vision
literature is that you
basically can just
sample random noise.
So, what would that
look like for us if we
wanted to just automatically
create errors?
Well, something we
do all the time is
we swap two letters, right?
You're typing, you
type too quickly,
you flip two letters.
So, we're going to
restrict that to being in
longer words and only in
the middle of the word,
say, sort of make
it a little easier
but noise goes to
nosey or something.
There's a meme that you might
remember from many years
back according to
research at Cambridge.
If you scramble
all the letters in
this word or something
to this effect,
you can still read it as long as
the first and last
letters stay put.
So, we're going to pretend like
the Internet knows things,
and we're going to go ahead and
follow the meme for
our second type of noise.
Third, what if we just
ignore that and randomly
permute all the letters in
the word and then finally,
all the time we end up
hitting a key by accident.
So, what happens if we swap
one of the letters with
one which is within a radius
one key on the keyboard?
The effect of this on
these two on the, sort of,
the two pre-trained, state
of the art fancy models is,
that as you change the number
of tokens that are
permuted or that are messed up,
you see the bleu scores drop off.
Not terribly surprising.
We see, for example,
is that by the time we get to
something like 20 percent,
we've actually lost almost half
of our performance, right?
Ten percent is still
a pretty steep drop-off
in both of these models.
So, it doesn't take a lot
to mess with translation.
I'll come back to what we might
do about it a little bit later.
The second thing you
might ask is, well,
these are some nice
synthetic results,
what does it look
like if we actually
try to use real noise?
So I said we have some Wiki
edits and stuff like this.
So, it turns out that there are
some beautiful people out
there that have created
these collections as
sort of second language speakers
in their edits to
them writing essays,
Wikipedia corpora
stuff like this.
So, we can go and we
can find a bunch of
naturally occurring
errors in the wild,
and then we can use them
to permute our text.
I don't speak a word of German,
but I'm told that what's
going on here is that,
for instance, we have phonetic
distinctions like T and D,
S and Z are getting screwed up.
We have dropped letters like
the T missing and
babysitter here.
Then we kind of get into
the more interesting space which
is things like morphological
problems, right?
So, where someone has conjugated
something incorrectly.
This is the kind of
stuff where if we
really want to be able to
do this automatically,
we're going to have
to have a much,
maybe, stronger notion
of linguistics to do
it than the kind of simple
errors I was presenting before.
So, the question becomes,
''Do these errors affect
our models in the same way
that our synthetic errors do?''
Yes. So, all I've done here,
is I've gone ahead
and superimposed,
this is the natural error line
on both of these.
It's just a hair better,
so maybe it's the case
that there are
certain types of errors
that are less likely
to be made then just
willy nilly swapping,
randomizing of letters.
So, for example,
maybe people are less
likely to mess up
a capitalization,
maybe people are less likely
to mess up, you know,
they may choose the wrong
conjugation but at least
it's a valid conjugation,
these kinds of things, right?
So, there's a quite a bit more
exploration that's
necessary there.
The other thing is
that we don't have
full token coverage because,
for example, we just don't
have errors for
every single word.
So, this maxes out
at about 40 percent.
Okay, so, as I started
with spell checkers.
So, like, obviously I said
they're not perfect but,
like, they're probably
like not terrible.
So, here's what happens
with our French,
German and Czech models,
if we just introduce
a bunch of natural errors.
So, here are our bleu scores.
Here's what happens
if we just select
the first spell
checker suggestion
for every single word in
the air-filled corpus.
So, what you first note is that,
first, French and German,
we are seeing
pretty significant gains,
something that unifies
six bleu points.
So, spell checkers
are doing something.
The other thing though that
I should mention is that,
in the case of French and German,
you're only seeing typically
one to two suggestions from
the spell checker for each
one of those recommendations.
That is not the case
for Czech, right?
So, when you look at
the Czech errors,
what ends up happening is,
you have this insane list
of all the things that
could possibly happen.
Again, I don't speak any Czech,
so I just picked the first one.
It turns out that actually
on average I made things worse.
So, that's sort of not,
you know, maybe for
the small error condition,
given sufficient contexts a rich,
spell checker would
be beneficial,
but those are also
going to break down.
Then just as a reminder, these
are still quite a
bit different from
what it would be like
if you just trained and
tested on clean text.
So, excuse me, now let's
try to see if we can do,
maybe, something
about robustness.
So, what about
training with noise.
So, there's way too many numbers,
and so if you're
really bored we've
just put charts and
charts on the paper.
So, I'm going to
try to synthesize
a couple of
quick lessons from it.
So one is, if I
train on noisy text,
but then I test on clean
unadulterated text, how do I do?
So, here what we've done is,
these are the different types
of vanilla is completely clean,
here are the different types
of noise that I
mentioned earlier and here's
what happens when I, sort of,
ensemble some of the noise
and for French and Czech,
so that this doesn't
get too cluttered.
Here is sort of ideally
where we would like to
be these lines and how well
the model is actually doing.
The thing that I want
to point out is that
the natural errors
are actually quite a
bit harder for some reason.
So, despite the fact that we,
you know, this is insane, right?
Here I've literally
scrambled the entire word,
and that doesn't affect
the model as much when
testing on the original data
as when I introduce
natural errors.
So, there's something that we
still need to investigate there.
Another thing though
that is somewhat
heartening is that at
least once you take the
natural and you add
other noise to it,
then the model becomes sort
of more generally robust.
Another thing that I'll point
out very quickly is what
happens if you test on
all different types of noise.
So, here what I've done
is we've trained on
a specific type of noise and then
I'm presenting The Average Bleu,
across five different types
of noise for testing.
So, for instance, just
to make this concrete,
here we just do the letter slop
inside of those words,
but the bleu score here
is when you test on swap,
middle, random keyboard
and natural.
So, all of those
and then average.
The first thing that I'd
like to point out is that
the model does seem in
some sense to have a robustness.
There's sort of the direction
of robustness, right?
So, if a model is trained
on words that are
totally randomized then it
does better on average
including on things that
were just these swaps than
if it sees less noise.
This seems to sort
of hold over to
the ensemble case, right?
So, once I throw
just tons and tons of
different noise at it,
the model seems to do
the best sort of overall.
All right. So, what
you would like to do.
So, if I was amazing at
cognitive modeling somehow,
I would build a model which not
only took into account noise but
also just like was impervious
to just didn't care.
We tried a bunch of fancy things
and they didn't
work and I can talk
about self attention
E-type things later.
So, what ended up
seeming to be fine was,
let's just try the main
character representation.
So, if I have a model
whose word representation
is just literally
the average of the vectors
for all the characters,
then it doesn't matter
what order they're in.
So, it's by definition
resilient to this.
So, there is the good news.
It means that I can train on
completely clean
text with no errors.
I can present it,
completely scrambled text,
and it still does okay.
So, I get 20 percent hit,
not the end of the world.
Then the thing that's not
surprising to anybody
in this room who's
ever thought about
language is that there
are morphologically
rich languages.
For which turns out you
really don't want to just
average all the characters,
there is something in the
structure of the word.
So, that's clearly
not the solution.
As one final note though.
So, I do want
ideally to be able to
move in this direction.
I'd like to be in
a situation where
models are more
inherently robust.
So, one thing we wanted
to do is at least analyze
what the filters of
the model we're learning,
when we're showing
various types of noise.
So, it's a little bit hard
to interpret all of this,
but let me just
focus on one point.
This is what happens if you
look at the weights in all
of the filters that are learned
for the character embeddings,
and our models when
they're trained in
these four different settings,
with keyboard errors,
natural errors,
completely randomized
ordering of the letters in
the word and the ensemble.
Note that these have
a pretty high variance.
So, you're learning different.
So, different filters are
going to be firing for
different settings, for
different environments.
Then note that when you train on
random, they've
completely collapsed.
So, what we think
is happening here,
is that basically when you
completely randomize
the input like that,
the models basically
rediscovering
that mean character
model from before.
It's basically giving up on
trying to learn structure.
So, it just takes
some an average of
everything that's in it
and then moves forward.
So, that seems to be
a baseline default.
Maybe we're even doing
something like that,
but we have additional systems
which can trigger,
if we're not understanding.
So, we can reason about things,
we can piece together
how we might unscramble
award and so forth.
So that's where we'd
like to move in
terms of future research. Thanks.
>> We have time for questions.
>> Thanks for the great talk.
So, have you thought about
what would be in the scenario
and adversarial noise?
What would really
screw up the system?
For the image
processing they will
like random would
sometimes screw up.
Is there like an adversarial
thing which will really.
>> So, it depends
on what you mean.
So It's two versions
of adversarial.
So, one is can you break
all these systems?
Obviously you can break
all these systems.
What we didn't do that
we played around a
little bit it's just
very time-consuming,
there are cases, where if I
change one of the letters,
I will change the translation.
So, it's quite possible that,
if I wanted to trick
a translation system
for example into
saying something in particular,
I might be able to make
some changes on the input,
which would cause that
but to which the human
wouldn't think of
as affecting it.
That's I think
the ideal adversarial case.
I don't have
a great notion for it.
We tried to do that manually,
and we were able to
find some examples.
I don't have
a pipeline as of yet,
but I think that would be
awesome if you could come up
with these examples. Yeah.
>> Hi, great talk.
I'm Engal from Boeing.
We deal with a lot of
very noisy text data.
For example, machine
is over the world,
maintain the airplane,
and they write poorly.
So, really interesting your talk.
So, did you try to deal
with abbreviations,
that chop off some of
the letters and sometimes
they insert letters too.
>> Yeah. So, we didn't
explicitly deal- I think
I actually skipped it.
They're not exactly
abbreviations but
definitely omissions is pretty
common in the edit corpora.
So, it is pretty
common for people to
just completely miss
a letter for example.
We're just starts to get
at this but no pursuit.
Particularly for instance
in an abbreviation,
you have even less to go on.
So, I suspect they'll just
make everything even harder,
but I don't have an answer to
what to do about any of this.
But, I don't.
Yeah. That's a great problem.
>> Also do you have
a sense how much
misspelled words
involved before you
are really not able to do as
well percentage
wise in a sentence?
>> Yes. So, it
becomes very clear.
So, we all have our experiences
with machine translation.
Where we run something
through and then
we even the best of cases,
we still have to do
some detective work to
figure out what was
actually intended.
So, in that sense, yeah.
Even that 10 percent mark,
if I'm just basically imagining
of a sentence and now
two of those words are
something randomly new,
the detective work becomes very,
very difficult to figure out
what was actually going on.
There's an example for
instance in the paper where we
run one of these fully
scrambled things through
Google Translate and also
the output from
these other systems,
you'd get out these sentences.
In some cases, the models
default to copying.
They're like, ''Oh,
well, I'll just take
the German straight
through and just hand
it back to you.''
In some cases, you get
what its attempt is
added a sentence.
It's just that it's
completely meaningless.
It has no bearing to what
was originally there.
So, I think the answer
is probably not
a lot and maybe a spellchecker
will be able to help you,
but I also want to
note that there's
a huge difference
between spellcheckers.
So, there's a difference between,
for instance,
the Google Translate,
spell checking that we
were doing here and if you
run like a spell on
your Unix machine.
So, having some
sentential context
is really important to being
able to address those errors.
Yeah.
>> Okay. Any more questions?
>> For your corpus
of natural errors,
I noticed you had some that were
the Wikipedia typos that
were probably from
native speakers,
but then you also had
language learners.
>> Right.
>> From a linguistic standpoint,
the errors made by
language learners
tend to be rather
different from native.
So, I was wondering if
you looked into how
those differ and
anything about that?
>> No. Unfortunately
we were mostly
focused on just
finding these errors,
but you're absolutely right.
I have to double-check
the details.
I think in the case of
the German and the Czech,
those are both language learners
and then in the case
of French and
English those are
Wikipedia edits.
I think that's partially
just an issue- its availability.
There just isn't as
much of that stuff.
But, I think that that's
another fascinating thing.
If we were to build these models
ideally that are robust,
we'd like to be able to introduce
these errors that require
someone to have first
collected or found
all this signs of things
and as the language
becomes not English resource.
Got it. So, yeah.
>> So, the third talk in
this session by Swabha.
She will talk about
Syntactic Scaffolds
for Semantic Structures.
>> Hi, I'm Swabha.
Can you hear me?
Okay. Yeah. I'll be talking
about Syntactic Scaffolds
for Semantic Structures,
and this is a work done jointly
with my co-authors, Sam,
who's right here, and Quentin,
Luke, Chris, and Noah,
who's right there.
Lots of affiliations,
literally, too many logos.
All right. So, the task we're
interested in is
Semantic Structure Prediction.
Now, depending on the formalism,
the semantic structures
may look very different.
For example, we
have the sentence,
Ivanka told Fei-Fei
that she is inspiring.
The frame semantics structure
for this sentence
looks like this.
There are two frames
of meaning, one,
about the event
telling and another
subjective influence.
For the telling frame,
the speaker is Ivanka,
the addressee is Fei-Fei,
and the message is
that she's inspiring.
For the subjective
influence frame,
the entity is she,
and she is providing
the influence.
So, this is what the frame
semantic structures look like.
A different kind of structure
is given by coreference,
where you have in green,
all the entities which are
present in the sentence,
as well as relationships
between the word she and Fei-Fei.
Hopefully, she refers to
Fei-Fei and not Ivanka.
Yeah. So, this is the kind of
structure that you get
from Coreference chains.
So, as you can see these
structures look very different.
The frame semantics looks quite
different from the
coref structure,
but what they have in common
is the syntactic framework.
So, for example, we
have the constituency tree
for the same sentence,
and we can see that
the different arguments
speaker is a noun phrase,
addressee is also a noun- phrase,
and the message is in S bar.
So, what you can see
from here is that,
if you have the syntactic
information of a sentence,
it might be easy to get to the
semantics of the sentence.
Indeed, this has been tried
extensively in previous work.
So, prior work involves
using a pipeline,
where given a sentence,
you first do
the syntactic processing
of the sentence to get
the full syntactic tree.
Use features from that tree to
extract the semantic
graphs from it.
Now, the problem
with this is that,
it is both very expensive,
and since you're doing
things in a pipeline,
you're very likely
to cascade errors.
If you get the syntax wrong,
you're very likely to also
get the semantics wrong.
Also, the tree that we saw in
the previous example is
way more complicated.
Whereas, the semantics was
relatively simple
like Jonathan said,
when people read sentences,
if they are trying
to semantically
understand the sentences
they did not read through
the entire sentence.
Some words can be skipped.
Some words are semantically
vacuous, and so on.
So, using syntax in
a pipeline works,
but it is probably not
the best solution.
Now, in recent times,
people have come up with
neural end-to-end models,
which have completely
done away with syntax.
So, these end-to-end models
just start with the sentence
and try to predict
the entire semantic graph
from the sentence.
Now, even though these models
work regardless of
not using syntax,
it has not been conclusively
shown that syntax does
not help further.
In fact, people from UW
[inaudible] , somewhere over here,
showed in her paper that using
constraints from
gold syntax actually helps.
So, there is still
hope for syntax.
There is actually a lot of hope.
So, what we are suggesting in
this work is somewhere in
between these two worlds.
We wanted to use syntax,
but we don't want to go
through this whole process of
pipelining and errors
cascading and so on.
So, what we are suggesting is
this method called Syntactic
Scaffolds, which users,
as the name suggest
syntax but does
not go through
the whole pipelining shrine.
Hopefully, I introduce
the problem to you.
Let's look in detail what
these Syntactic Scaffolds are.
So, this is essentially
a multi-task learning setup,
where one of the tasks is
the primary task we
are interested in,
which is the semantic
structure prediction does,
frame semantics or
coref in our case,
and the second task is
syntactic prediction.
However, in contrast to
your traditional
multi-task learning setup,
where both the tasks
are equally important.
For us, the syntactic task
is a secondary auxiliary tasks,
and the primary task is
the semantic tasks that
we're interested in.
So, multitask learning
gives us this advantage,
that we can use
shared parameters to learn
better contextualized
representations for the spans and
whatever substructures that
are semantically non-raculous.
Also, in this setup,
as an channeled
multitask learning,
we do not need the supervision
for the semantics
and syntax to come on
from the same data set.
So, we can use
two different data sets,
one with only semantic
annotations and other with
only syntactic annotations
and still be able to learn,
which is difficult in
your regular pipeline setup,
because you need the syntax on
the same data before you can
predict semantics on it.
Another thing that the
syntactic scaffolds
approach offers us,
is that we do not have to predict
this entire complicated
syntactic tree
with all its bells and whistles.
We just have to focus on
the substructures in
that syntactic tree,
which are meaningful for
the semantic prediction task.
We'll look at some of
the substructures later on.
Finally, as the name
suggests, it's a scaffold,
so it is only used at
learning time to learn
the model with all the
syntactic information in it,
and at test time,
we can totally discard
this and move on.
All right. So,
the learning problem
looks something like this.
So, this is the
objective equation,
one shows us the objective.
The first term in the objective
is the primary objective,
the syntactic structure
prediction objective,
which we will look into later.
The secondary objective is
the scaffold objective,
both are interpolated
by this term,
delta, which is
a mixing ratio that
tells you how do we relate
these two objectives.
So, all you have to do is plug-in
the scaffolding objective
into your semantic objective,
and you will be able to
learn information from
the syntactic tree bank.
If you look into
the objective, what it does,
it's a simple logistic
regression classifier.
It takes all possible spans in
the sentence up to
a certain length and
tries to predict
for each span what
the syntactic substructure
of that span could be,
whether or not it's
a noun phrase,
what kind of noun phrase it is,
what the parent of the noun
phrase could be, and so on.
So to formalize it,
the different substructures
we tried to predict,
Phrase Identity, whether
or not a span is
a constituent phrase
or a syntactic phrase,
the phrase type of the span.
If the span is not
a syntactic phrase,
we predict null, the
phrase type and the parent
phrase type of the span.
This parent phrase type
is the constituent that
immediately precedes it in
the tree and
special phrase types,
such as noun phrase and
prepositional phrase.
That is given a span,
whether or not, it is
a noun phrase or
a prepositional phrase.
We do this because a
lot of these arguments,
as we saw the names,
Ivanka and Fei-Fei.
They were noun phrases,
and a lot of and
semantic arguments tend
to be noun phrases.
A lot of semantic
arguments tend to
be prepositional
phrases and so on.
Okay. So, let's look at some of
the the two downstream tasks that
we incorporated
this framework in.
The first one is Frame-Semantics.
So, again, this is what
a Frame-Semantic graph
looks like.
We are using the FrameNet corpus,
which was created at Berkeley.
In this particular work,
we only focus on the task
of identifying and
labeling these spans.
So, given a sentence,
as well as the frames
in the sentence,
that is if we know that there is
a frame telling in the sentence,
and if you know there is a frame
subjective influence
in the sentence,
are we able to predict what
the arguments for
those frames are?
This frame identification and
also, target identification
tasks are relatively
straightforward,
and have been solved previously
with high accuracy but
argument labeling and argument
identification on
difficult tasks,
so we focus only on that.
As a baseline, we use this model
called Semi-Markov CRFs,
which is a
generalization of a CRF.
So, the generalization only
comes from the simple fact,
that you have to predict
for a given sentence.
You predict a segmentation
of the sentence.
So, in a general CRF,
each segment is of
the same fixed length,
which is typically one.
A Semi-Markov CRF
offers you the freedom,
wherein the length modelling,
also the length of the segment
that you're predicting.
So, this works very well
for our case because
arguments can have
arbitrary lengths.
So, this is a natural fit
for the task of frames
semantic parsing.
Without going into
too many details,
I'll just say that we focus
on spans up to length D. So,
if you had to model
every possible span in
the sentence of length N,
you would run into O of
N square complexity,
and we pare it down to O of ND
because we only limit
ourselves to spans of
length D. The factor L comes from
the different possible labels
that you could label a span with.
All right and to model
the spans themselves,
we use an architecture like this.
This is from coauthors,
Canton and Luke.
So, how this model works
is given a sentence,
we first get the
pretrained embeddings
for that sentence
we use clav here,
we pass it through
two bi-directional LSTMs to get
the contextualized
representations of
each token in the sentence.
These are given by
the yellow embeddings
and to represent a span
what we do is we take
the first word in
the span and the last
word and concatenate
the hidden representation of
both words and we also use
this head finding mechanism
that finds the head or it
uses a simple attention
mechanism to figure
out what word in the span carries
the most syntactic information
and that is given by
the red nodes over there and
the final span representation
is given as the green vectors.
Okay, so all we do in
the scaffolded Frame SRL
is plug-in this objective.
So, the primary objective
as shown on top,
it is a modified
log-likelihood objective
and all we do now is use
the same span representations or
use the same parameters to learn
these span representations and
plug-in the
scaffolding objective.
A scaffolding objective is
trained on two nodes data,
which is built on
top of Penn Treebank
and the primary objective
is trained on freeman.
So, here since we have
two different corpora
we can get by even though
there is no data overlap.
All right, so, looking
at some results
our baseline semi-CRF model gets
a significant improvement
over previous state of
the art models and
as we add these different
scaffolding models,
we keep on seeing improvements.
So, this shows that adding
syntactic information is
still useful and
the best model that we have,
which is shown in gray
is this particular
scaffolding model,
which takes a span and
predicts whether or
not it should be a noun phrase
or a prepositional phrase.
So, getting very
specific seem to help.
All right, I'll quickly
go over the next task,
which is coreference resolution,
this is also a span-based task.
So, we use this model
from Canton and others
where this task is treated as
a series of sequence
classification tasks.
So, spans in
the sentence are labeled
as entities and also you
label for a given entity what is
the antecedent entity to
that particular entity.
So, this way, you can build
these simple
classification decisions
to get entity clusters.
So, again, all we do is since
we are doing
a span-based modelling
for the coreference model,
we can use the same
span representation
to make the classification
of what kind
of syntactic span it is and
so it's again very simple,
just plug in and interpolate
with this delta.
Again, we see an improvement
when we plug in
the scaffolding objective
and the improvement is
not as much as we
saw in the frame net task
and this could be
attributed to the fact that we do
this again on the
onto notes task,
where the way
the coreference mentions
were annotated were on top
of these syntactic constituents.
So, you already have
that information in
the data and you're
reusing the data to learn
these syntactic constituents.
So, it is possible that,
that is why the improvement
is not as much.
So, in summary, we saw that
syntax is very useful
for semantics,
but syntax is expensive,
so scaffolds are
an inexpensive alternative
that can get the
best of both worlds.
Okay, so what's next so
this is not something
that is confined to
only semantic tasks
basically any task that uses
syntactic span information could
benefit from such scaffolding.
Syntactic dependencies
could be used as
scaffolds too and finally,
you can use semantics
as scaffolds
for various downstream tasks.
So, that's all.
>> Question.
>> There is one there.
>> Can I ask
the differences between
the recurrent neural
network together with
the classification on top of it
and the recursive neural
network, standard recursive.
>> Right. So, you can think
of recursive neural nets
as like a special case of
recurrent neural networks.
So, basically to build
a recursive neural net,
you need to know
what structure it is
modelling for which
you need to know
that there is some kind of
a syntactic tree and you will
use that syntactic tree to
compose together the nodes,
but here we are just
modeling the sentences,
we don't have any information
about structure.
So, we cannot really use
recursive neural nets
in this case,
but it is another way to
represent information
like these graphical information
or tree-specific information.
>> So, great presentation.
If you wanted to enhance
where you are going beyond
a frame induction and capture
more semantics like
possession and
negation and some of
these other types of things,
would you need to
go more into doing
grammatical dependency types of
relationships rather than
these span-based representations.
>> Yeah, of course. So, we've
actually been thinking about
doing similar things for
these national language
inference-based tasks,
where relationships
between words is
shown to be enough to predict
inference relationships
between these hypotheses and
premises and that is where
the syntactic dependency
scaffolds is hoped to help
the most because yeah,
it really depends on the task.
So, here we had
two span-based tasks and
so we saw that these span-based
scaffolding things help,
but it really depends
on the end task,
so you typically if
you wanted to do
very good multitask learning,
you typically want
to learn structures,
which are kind of similar,
but there is nothing
to say that if
you learn from
different structures,
you can't get anything.
I don't have experimental
results to show that,
but it's also possible.
>> Thank you.
>> I was just curious
if you've done only POS
tagging as the other objective
instead of constituency.
>> Yeah, so that's
a good question.
So, there has been related
work that does POS
tagging as one of
the tasks in this multitask
learning scenario.
We did not do that
because we were
more interested in these
more complicated
structural tasks,
but people have used POS as
one of the maybe the
auxiliary part of
the scaffolding tasks that
does work from you have
Goldberg and others who have
done similar things
and saw improvements,
but yeah that's also
another alternative.
>> Thank you.